[Music]
the new year might be a good reason to
find a new resolution but we think that
you should get in shape whenever you
feel like it simply because this is the
best thing to do for your body it all
starts with a good diet to have the
right energy to move around all day
make sure you watch this video until the
end to see what you should drink before
every meal if you love health as much as
we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 20 foods that
might help you lose weight whole fruits
you have probably heard about juicing
some people drink a lot of juice or even
drink only juice because they think that
it will make them lose weight but that's
not true what you should do instead is
to eat whole fruits
that's because juice is relatively high
in calories and won't keep you as full
as solid food will so you'll end up
drinking more a whole fruit provides
more micronutrients for the same number
of calories with more fibers the feeling
of fullness will be increased and the
absorption of calories will also
decrease this is why a whole fruit and a
glass of water will be better for your
diet quinoa this food is becoming more
and more popular now that people know
its benefits
that's because quinoa is not only
filling but also loaded with nutritional
value including nutrients that might
help you lose weight the protein in the
quinoa is also harder to break down than
carbs or fat so you'll also burn more
calories during digestion this is what
makes it part of the best meals to start
the day and it's also very easy to eat
quinoa every day that's because this
food has a neutral flavor this is why it
works in many types of dishes and you'll
never be tired of eating it however is
high in calories so you should keep
yourself from eating too much pasta if
you think that pasta will make you gain
weight that's because you're not eating
it the right way
pasta is also considered a grain which
should always be included in your diet
pasta is fortified with protein and
fiber to keep your body from absorbing
things too quickly which makes it one of
the best carbohydrates that you can find
this is also one of the best things to
eat if you've exercised a lot because it
replenishes your body's energy store and
keeps blood sugar from dipping too low
pasta gives you a lot of energy
as long as you can spend it it won't
make you gain weight whole eggs stop
wasting any part of your egg when you
are eating it many people stop eating
eggs when they found out about their
high cholesterol and fat content but
surprisingly doctor said that adding a
little bit of cholesterol to your diet
won't increase cholesterol levels in
your body and anyway this risk factor
for cardiovascular disease is not as
important as we once thought whole eggs
actually contain nutrients that are
really good for your health including
choline and sometimes omega-3 so if you
like eggs don't keep yourself from
eating some tomorrow morning your body
will thank you
salmon this type of fish is high in
nutrients with reasonable calories and
once your body gets all the nutrients it
needs it won't ask you to eat more than
you should it also includes vitamin b12
which is an essential part of your diet
even though you want to protect animals
that live on earth salmon is full of
lean proteins that will make you feel
full longer and does not spike blood
sugar but don't forget that there is no
miracle food that is suddenly going to
make you thinner you always need a whole
reduced calorie diet and regular
exercise if you want to lose weight
potatoes who said the potatoes were bad
for your shape sure eating french fries
is not the best idea but there are many
ways you can eat potatoes and stay
healthy
a man adopted the potato only diet for a
year to lose weight and this is how he
lost 50 kilograms by the way eating only
one food is always going to be a
terrible idea but it can still show you
that potatoes won't make you gain weight
and they can still be part of a healthy
diet as long as you eat plain potatoes
instead of baked or fried potatoes it
won't affect your diet soup eating soup
before every meal could be the key to
success you might feel like you are
eating more food but actually eating
soup will make you feel fuller and you
won't need to eat as much when the main
meal is served
it will also force you to slow down this
is how you will consume 20% fewer
calories during the whole meal as long
as the soup is low-calorie
moreover eating soup is a great way to
add water to your diet just give it a
try
and you can see that eating soup is a
great way to get in shape
avocado we totally understand why
Millennials
love avocado toast is become one of the
best parts of their diet this is because
eating avocado is a simple way to
prevent metabolic syndrome
it's a term used to describe a
combination of three or more risk
factors for heart disease and diabetes
like high blood pressure or a large
waist circumference avocado has a
beneficial effect on cholesterol levels
and can help stave off belly fat which
is the most dangerous type of fat this
is why this creamy fruit should be added
to your diet and is even better if you
can eat it every day nuts you will go
nuts on this new diet for years people
didn't eat nuts because of their high
fat content but we found out that they
should actually be part of a healthy
diet
they contain mono saturated fat vitamin
E folic acid magnesium copper protein
and fiber they can also reduce the risk
of heart disease and can help lower bad
cholesterol levels
moreover nuts are really filling so you
won't feel hungry after eating them as
always as long as you don't overdo it
nuts can help you lose weight and it's
even better if you can add it to the
next thing on our list yogurt one of our
favorite snacks is adding some nuts to
yogurt
don't ever think that you need to starve
yourself to lose weight because your
body will just want you to eat more and
you will be able to resist the
temptation eating yogurt as a snack is a
great solution because it is low in
calories but also full of nutrients and
you can get the most out of every meal
it's also high in calcium which
increases body fat breakdown and
preserves metabolism during dieting
increasing your calcium intake can
reduce belly fat and you'll also have
the chance to eat more delicious snacks
during the day dark chocolate being on a
diet doesn't mean that you can never
treat yourself that's because eating a
small amount of dark chocolate every day
can crow cravings for both sweet and
salty foods the antioxidants in
chocolate can also help block the
breakdown of fat and carbohydrates so
less food gets absorbed into your
bloodstream and it can't get socked away
in your fat cells it can also lower
blood pressure and boost the good
cholesterol as always you shouldn't
overdo it but if you always had a sweet
tooth eating a little bit of dark
chocolate every day could I
would be good for your diet spinach
here's something new that you need to
try add a cup of spinach every day to
help weight loss spinach is a
low-calorie food and also a great source
of dietary fiber that boosts satiety
fiber is in fully absorbed into your
body so it helps you fill up but it
doesn't make you gain weight what you
need to do is replace high-calorie foods
with spinach to reduce your overall
calorie intake it can be added to many
different types of meals so you will be
able to eat it every day or at least
several times a week it's also a great
reason to discover new recipes tuna this
type of fish already has a great
reputation as a healthy food because
it's loaded with essential nutrients
that boost your overall health and
well-being it helps with weight loss
because of its high protein content and
low calorie counts protein is hard to
digest so your body will burn more
calories by trying to break down the
protein this is how eating becomes one
of the best ways to get in shape just
make sure that you choose the right kind
of tuna if you really want to be thinner
we suggest you in a steak or a tuna cans
and water for better results beans there
are so many reasons why you should start
eating more beans right now
the pulses boost satiety and curb
cravings for processed snacks so you'll
end up eating less food after this it
also boosts calorie and fat burning
because it contains an amino acid that
increases carbohydrates and fat burning
it also offers heart protection because
it has an impact on cholesterol and
blood pressure some people say that it
caught Drupal's weight loss and it has
been proven by scientists there are even
more reasons why you should add themes
to your diet and this is why you should
go buy some right after watching this
video grapefruits this is one of the
best fruits you can eat if you're on a
diet as long as you don't eat it with a
ton of sugar however don't believe the
myth that grapefruit burns fat you
should never think that eating one thing
all the time is good for you and that
losing 10 pounds in 10 days is healthy
because it will just make things worse
the real reason why this fruit is good
is that it helps you feel full so you'll
tend to eat less this is why eating
grapefruit for breakfast is a great way
to start your day don't believe
everything you see online and don't
forget that you should always listen to
your body
oats one of the best ways to start the
day is listen
oats for breakfast that's because they
are packed with nutrients like healthy
carbs and fiber and there is no reason
why you can't go on a diet - because
oats are really affordable anyone can
try it don't say that you don't like the
taste because there are many ways you
can eat them just make sure that you
don't eat too many sugary instant oats
if you don't like things as they are
change them you are the only one who is
keeping you away from your goals brown
rice everyone likes rice and it's easy
to make them part of any meal even
though it's not low in calories it can
add nutritional value to a diet as long
as you eat plenty of other healthy
things it's also full of fiber and we
already know that it's been associated
with a lot of health benefits when you
want to lose weight moreover it's really
easy to prepare an incredibly versatile
even though any kind of rice is good
brown rice has fewer calories which
makes it the best choice for anyone who
is on a diet Barry we know that you want
to eat sweets and when you're on a diet
eating a ton of [ __ ] is not a good
idea but don't worry there is always a
really easy solution eating fruits
berries are full of antioxidants that
acts like body guards protecting cells
from damage like premature aging and
disease they are also linked to weight
control because people who consume more
antioxidants weigh less some berries
also reduce blood sugar and insulin
levels after meals and connect as
metabolism boosters they are also full
of fiber and you know how much we love
them this is why they make a great
dessert if you want to treat yourself
after dinner vegan food many people
became vegan simply because they cared
about animals and this is when they
found out that it was actually a great
way to lose weight when you're a vegan
it's hard not to eat anything healthy
you have to change most of your eating
habits and saving the animals can be a
great motivation to reach your goals
moreover when you are part of a
community it's easier to feel supportive
a vegan diet gives you more energy and
this is how you are going to be able to
exercise more and lose weight becoming
vegan might be a huge change in your
life but you won't want to go back once
you feel all the benefits water it might
not be food but water will always be the
most
part of your diet you should drink a
little bit of water every two hours to
be healthy and to make sure that there
won't be too much water in your body at
the same time if you don't like just
drinking water you can always add
flavour ops for green iced tea eat
fruits full of water or eat soup one
easy way to lose weight is to simply
drink one glass of water before every
meal so you will feel fuller are you
going to try any of these foods this
year can you think of any other healthy
food don't be shy to answer in the
comments section down below we'd love to
hear what you think and that's it for 20
foods that help you lose weight for more
stories like this
make sure you watch 10 myths about food
you still believe thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]